皆さんは東武線によく聞かれたりしますか
私も子供の頃よく一体今でも家族一緒に遊びに対しています
ところでこの動物園私たち家族が楽しむという以外にも他に役割があることをご存知
ですか
現在近代的な動物園では家族のリクリエーション
以外にも動物保全教育研究などといった動物たちが直面する問題を解決する非常に重要
な役割を果たしています
ところでこの動物たちが直面している問題とは一体何でしょうか
それは彼らの未来です
皆さんはどれだけの動物たちがその存在
絶滅の危機に瀕しているかご存じでしょうか
実に3000種以上もの動物たちがその絶滅の危機に瀕しています
これには私たちがよく動物園などにかける
ゴリラやチンパンジーなども含まれてみます
想像してみてください
その
ゴリラや審判地たちが動物園はもちろん
地球上から来姿を消してしまうというその光景を
そして身近にいたはずの動物たちがまあ深くいなくなってしまうというその景色を
それが現実のものとなってしまうのかもしれないんです
また
同部戦で保護されている動物殺にも問題は起きます
こちらのタスマニアデビルです
これは
眼下によって顔面が変形してしまうという原因不明の病気があります
また動物園で保護されているゴリラもを心臓病にかかりやすいといった
やはり県不明の疾患があります
このように
同部前で方されている動物たちもいた湖行気になってしまったとき
また機がをしてしまったとき
効果的な治療法はないということが問題なのです
もちろん動物園ではこういった治療法を開発するために様々な努力が進められています
しかし対象となるのが彼ら絶滅危惧種です
いかんせん子研究に必要なサンプルを少なく
治療法の開発は遅々として進んでいません
ここで私たちが買い付けせなければいけない点は2点あります
まず1つは動物たちを実験に使わない
いや使えない
そしてでも彼らの病気を治したい
1件このように矛盾する二つの花材を同時に解決する必要があるのです
そしてこれを可能にする
研究が私たちが行っている
ボディオンチップです
今日はぜひこの名前を覚えて帰ってください
このボディオンチップはコンピューター開発などに使われる
加工技術を使ってこの私たちの体の中に起きている仕組みを小さなチップの中で再現
しようとそういう試みです
つまりこの技術を使って私は絶滅危惧種を人工的に小さなチップの上で再現しそれを
使って彼らに対する有効な治療法を開発します
これまでにも
私たちの体をこの身体の外で再現するという試みや長年研究として行われてきました
そしてその研究には細胞が主張されています
これは生物の構成単位です
これを使うことによって
体の中の仕組みがわかるだけでなく病気のメカニズム解明やそれに関わる
薬品の開発さらには再生医療への応用などが期待されるからです
そしてこの細胞は私たちの体の中で神経や心臓
筋肉などさまざまな組織を構成しています
そのはず実に37長考にも上ります
するにしてだいたい270種類くらいです
そしてこれらの細胞は体の中でランダムに存在しているというわけではありません
組織それぞれの構造を持ってその機能を発揮しています
つまり私たちがこの身体を
も仕組みを真似するためには組織の構造自身を真似する必要があるのです
ただ現在私たちが使用している
現在の細胞培養法
には
これらの構造真似できない重大な欠点があります
こちらが現在私たちが使用している細胞蠅をフラスコです
この中で細胞を培養しています
こう一貫してもわかると思いますけれどもこの中で
人や絶滅危惧種を再現しようとすることは到底無理なるです
信じらんねーかもしれませんが私たちはこの細胞培養フラスコを実に100人以上も
使用しています
ですが同時に私たちはこの夫妻ボウフラそこには限界が来ているということも知ってい
ます
細胞や組織
彼らがちゃんとした機能を発揮するために新しいツールが必要となっているのです
ここからが私の出番となります
今回の徹底楠橋東2016で私の自己紹介は生物甲殻研究者
となっています
一般的に古生物系の研究者といいますと研究室で交通とこう顕微鏡法ずつ除いている
そういうイメージを持たれているかもしれません
ですが私の本職
細胞のための建築家です
建築家です
これは
細胞のための快適な家づくりをしているようなものです
それはたとえば人が住めるようなもしくはここにあるような行動とか家とかを作成して
いるわけではなく
米粒よりもさらに小さな小さな小さな家を
細胞に提供しています
そしてその細胞たちがその環境で良い環境でいい機能を発揮するための家を提供して
いる
それが私の職業なんです
そういった技術を集結してできたのがボディオンチップです
これがその実物になります
を小さい中ですよね
これ使って私たちは生物を再現しようとしているのです
を信じられますかこんな小さなチップの上で
動物や人を再現しようとしているんですよ
例えば私ですと170センチ身長170cm 体重は一応不明としておきますけれども
そういった
この大きな体がこの小さなチップの中に再現できるのです
そしてそれを使って今までの実験法ではできなかった
組織の再構築が可能になり
今まではできなかった身体の中で近い環境で実験
さらには研究が行なえるようになるのです
これまでにも
body 女チップの一つ前のバージョンとして臓器チップというものが開発されてい
ました
この臓器チップは
一つの臓器を一つのチップに再現しているだけでした
またこの臓器チップでは生体の中からだの中で非常に重要な機能を一つ再現できてい
ませんでした
それは血管などの循環器です
それぞれに早期はこの結果などを通してお互いに影響しあっています
そしてその影響は無視できないものです
これまでの臓器チップではそういった臓器間の相互作用というものが再現できず
からだとやはり少し違ったものとなっていました
そこで私たちが開発している body 女チュッ
イワン複数の臓器と循環器が搭載されています
これを使うことによって
今まではできなかったような人のせい力の
これからだのしくみをこの中で再現することに成功しているのです
例えば
昔から問題になっている抗がん剤の副作用
それをこのチップの中で再現することに世界で初めて成功しています
またこういった複数の組織やらさらに
循環器こういった小さなチップで再現するということは世界中を探しても私たちの研究
チームにしかできません
こういったボディオンチップの研究は現在世界中で着目が集まっています
例えば
アメリカでは政府研究関連機関が100工場記念もの研究費を
ハーバード大学などに投入しています
またヨーロッパでも
やはり産官学連携プロジェクトに対して教育の研究資金を投入しているところです
日本では
ここ最近になってようやくその重要性が着目されるようになってきました
japan をクリアとっていますがまだトリスもせます
日本のみなさん頑張っていきましょう
さてこのボディオンチップですが
今では人に関する
健康で人の健康に関するものでした
もちろんそれでします非常に重要なことです
ですが動物たちに対してはどうでしょうか
もしこれを動物たちの例えば健康診断であるとか
一応法の開発であるとかそういったものに出場できれば
帰ら飲み会があるのではないかが明るくなるのではないかそういうふうに考えました
つまり絶滅危惧種オンチップ開発できれば
彼らを助けます
ただこれを開発するにあたって
押さなければいけないハードルがあります
それは細胞です
このチップにはさまざまな組織細胞を搭載する必要があります
ただいかんせん対象となるのは絶滅危惧種です
彼だからこそ細胞を採取してこの中に入れるといったことは有り得ません
それを解く鍵となるのが
ips 細胞です
ただしヒト由来のものではありません
絶滅危惧襲来のものです
この ips 細胞には2つの重要な性質があります
まず自分自身を何回でも複製できる自己複製の
さらにどんな細胞にでもなりうる分可能です
つまりこの細胞を使うことによって
様々な必要な組織を十分な量だけ準備することができるのです
ただ
そもそもこの ips アップ自身の材料となる細胞はどうしたらいいのでしょうか
そこで私たちが注目したのが動物の毛根
系です
動物の毛というのは比較的を動物にダメージを与えることなく最初することができます
その毛根から
細胞採取しさらに by 要素
それを使って ips 細胞を作ることが可能になるのです
もちろんこれを使えば必要な組織を必要な量だけ準備することができるので
絶滅女チップが
完成することができます
これを使えば
絶滅危惧種に対する病気のメカニズム解明
さらにそれにあった薬品の開発
さらには再生医療への応用が期待できます
これが絶滅危惧種オンチップです
最後になりますが
私にも人に娘がいます
まあたぶんここにあ見つけましたいいますねこれも着せています
買い物であのまあ動物園に行ったりしますとココリラチンパンジーなどを見たり
さらに淫行小さい行動不察とこ遊んだりするのが好きなようです
私はそういったは私たちの子どもやその子どもをもちろんそれだけではなく動物たちの
子どもやその子供もそういった
次の世代のため
彼らの明るい未来のためにこういった動物
絶滅危惧種温湿布が役に立つその未来への架け橋となる
そう強く信じています
ご静聴ありがとうございました